Hallo, Wolfgang.
Hallo, Stefan.
Schon wieder Salon.
Ja, wir stehen davor und du warst im Kino. Hast du mir jetzt gesagt und ich bin verwundert. Also du bist jetzt wieder häufiger, glaube ich, nach der Pandemie im Kino als vor der Pandemie, oder?
Das stimmt. Ich habe jetzt auch Dune noch mal zu Hause geguckt. Mir ist noch was ganz Neues aufgefallen, was mir vorher gar nicht aufgefallen ist. Und zwar die Fremen, die sich ja kompletto ihrer Natur unterwerfen. Wir kommen heute auch bei Harald Wälzer darauf zurück. Das ist ja ganz interessant, dass wir die Natur nicht so Kulisse oder ach, können wir mal ausbeuten, machen wir uns Untertan und so, sondern die wissen, also hier kommt es auf jeden Tropfen an. Und zur Begrüßung rotzen die sich auf den Tisch, weil sie damit zeigen, wir spenden dir einen kleinen Tropfen Wasser. Also die Fremen scheinen mir so eine Interstelleraussage zu haben, so eine Interstellartige Botschaft des Filme-Macher oder so.
Der Roman wurde ja auch schon damals ökologisch dann rezipiert und ich glaube, dass man das mit dem Film jetzt auch wieder machen kann. Und ich war auch im Kino, war in dem neuen Film von Ridley scott.
Gucci.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, The Last Duel, dieser Ritterfilm, in dem es darum geht, eine Vergewaltigung, die dort stattfindet, aus mehreren Perspektiven zu erzählen. Also einmal aus der Perspektive des Täters, einmal aus der Perspektive des Ehemanns, des Opfers und einmal aus der Perspektive der Frau. Und das erinnert selbstverständlich an den Klassiker Rashomon. Aber Rashomon ist ein grandioses Meisterwerk und war wirklich innovativ und hat da Maßstäbe gesetzt. Und Ridley scott weiß aber eigentlich gar nichts damit anzufangen, sondern zeigt uns eigentlich redundant das immer, immer wieder. Es ist keine konstruktivistische Haltung dazu, sondern es wird halt ein bisschen die Kamera verrückt. Der eine sieht das, der eine sieht das, der andere das. Aber es ist überhaupt nicht so, dass man es hier mit einem intelligenten Umgang damit zu tun hat, also mit Realitätskonstruktion oder so. Oder dass es wirklich darum geht, dass die Sichtweise, die Empfindung des Opfers eine ganz andere ist, die uns dann vermittelt wird. Also ein Film, der zwar zweieinhalb Stunden dauert, aber einen doch sehr ratlos zurücklässt und viele Redundanzen bietet. Umso gespannter bin ich, wie Ridley scott sich mit der Gucci-Story schlagen wird. Denn The House of Gucci kommt in einem Monat in die Kinos. Und das wird ja für mich dann sehr wichtig, als Mode interessierter, auch wenn ich keine Gucci-Dinge besitze. Ich glaube, doch eine Sonnenbrille habe ich von Gucci mir mal vor vielen Jahren gekauft. Aber ich besitze keine Mode davon, weil ich auch diese Logos nicht so irgendwie groß haben will, auf einer Krawatte oder was. Aber das wird auf jeden Fall ein Film, der mich sehr interessiert, unkoppig gut besetzt. Und ob man da was über die Mode wirklich erfährt oder worum es da eigentlich geht.
Ridley scott kann ja den Kostümen filmen, das haben wir ja 2000 gesehen mit Gladiator. Alle halbnackte Darstellen und tolle Kulissen bauen. Das ist ja der Auftrag in Gucci. Der andere Film, von dem du gerade erzählt hast, der scheint ja mehr so ein Kammer-Spiel zu sein. Ich weiß auch nicht, warum er sich da immer so verirrt bei solchen Sachen.
Ja, es gibt ja nachher noch ein paar größere Schleiften. Die sind extrem brutale, aber eigentlich ist das tatsächlich so kammerspielhaft. Und bei Gucci muss er ja schon auch diese Unternehmenskultur zeigen. Er muss die Mode zeigen. Was ist jetzt vielleicht auch das Genialische daran? Und gute Filmemacher müssen eigentlich dann noch mal erkennen, dass sie nicht so ein Museum inszenieren. Das ist ja die große Gefahr, dass wenn man dann auf die Mode blickt, dass man schon den Eindruck hat, ach ja, das ist musealisiert, das ist jetzt noch mal so abgehangen, oder das ist noch mal nachgeschneidert worden. Aber man muss ja verstehen, Mode findet ja immer im Hier und Jetzt statt. Und wird dann auch als Hier und Jetzt Mode wie selbstverständlich getragen. Und nicht musealgetragen. Und das ist ganz schwierig, wenn man einen Film über Mode macht, dass man nicht ins Museum läuft. Das ist ein bisschen auch das Problem der beiden Yves Saint Laurent-Filme, die es gibt, die nicht ganz schlecht sind. Vor allem der, in dem Helmut Berger mitspielt. Erfährt man doch einiges und der hat auch seine Stärken. Aber so ganz glücklich war das bislang alles nicht so. Es gibt einen guten Film über Mode, aber das ist der seidene Faden. Das ist etwas, was man sich ansehen kann. Der seidene Faden.
Das würdest du mal richtig empfehlen als Film über Mode.
Jaja, auf jeden Fall, aber sonst wird... Aber das ist auch wieder kein Film über Mode, sondern es ist eigentlich ein Liebesfilm. Aber es ist sehr schwierig, einen Film über Mode zu machen, glaube ich. Auch wenn man erst mal sagt, das ist ja naheliegend, denn man hat ja was Visuelles.
Ja, also ich habe ja keinen Plan für einen Gucci. Ich sehe nur auf Instagram Don Johnson auf dem Hollywood-Boulevard rumlungern, wie da eine Gucci-Show auf der Straße stattfindet, auch pandemiebedingt und so weiter. Das wiederum fand ich ziemlich cool aus, weil da fand die Mode mal in der Kulisse statt, wo sie auch wirklich getragen werden kann. Ohne jetzt zu übertriebenes Zeug, sondern es war schon, es hat irgendwie gepasst. Hollywood Boulevard und so weiter.
Also Präterpottee.
Ja, ja, so ein bisschen. Partymaterial irgendwie. Und bei Gucci, dem Film achte ich dann, also da kommt es mir dann sehr auf deine Filmanalyse an, ob du Hinweise gibst, dass die Ironie, die im Trailer angelegt ist, ein bisschen funktioniert. Dass sie da über die Stränge schlagen, was sie ja auch modisch im Trailer schon machen. Also die kleiden ja die Ü50-Männer da wirklich in gruseliges Zeug. Also da bin ich mal sehr gespannt. Selten war ein Trailer in der Kürze dann doch so aussagekräftig irgendwie, was die Art und Weise des Films angeht. Lady Gaga und so, ich bin mal sehr gespannt.
Ja, die Marke ist ja sehr, sehr berühmt, aber sie ist auch nicht so richtig vornehmen, um es mal so auszudrücken. Also wenn man durch Düsseldorf geht, dann kommt man auch zum Beispiel an Gucci vorbei. Und ich sage es mal so, da stehen merkwürdige Leute vor der Tür.
Gut, andere merkwürdige Leute. Darüber wollte ich eigentlich sprechen. James Bond, denn da haben wir mehr als ein Trailer. Da haben wir den ganzen Film. Und du fandst ihn nicht gut. Ich habe mir deine Filmanalysen dazu noch nicht angesehen. Weiß aber, du... Sagen wir mal so, ich... Ich habe über Filmanalysen gesprochen, die man nicht gesehen hat. Ich vermute, du magst an James Bond nicht, dass wir ihn jetzt wirklich mal als... Menschenvater und so weitersehen, und nicht nur als Touristagent und Pipapo.
Ich möchte eine Comicfigur da sehen, wie das über all die Jahrzehnte war. Und ich möchte nicht den heruntergeschrumpft bekommen zu einem Patchwork-Familienvater, der morgens das Müsli macht. Das ist mir zutiefst zuwider.
So, und dann habe ich deinen Tweet zu deiner Filmanalysen gesehen und habe gedacht, oh, oh, oh, der schlechteste Bond aller Zeiten. Und Jammerlappenfiel auch schon mal irgendwann.
Ja, das ist ein Jammerlappenbond.
Jedenfalls habe ich dann Angst bekommen, weil ich finde ja, seit Casino Royale sind das ja eigentlich schon ganz gute Bondfilme. Casino Royale sticht aber wirklich mit großem Abstand so heraus. Und ich habe gedacht, okay, das ist jetzt das Finale, alle wissen Bescheid, das muss noch mal an Casino Royale irgendwie anschließen. Und da haben wir auch so einen liebenden Bond, einen leidenden Bond und so weiter gesehen. Und dann hatte ich die Befürchtung, dass du recht hast mit deiner Filmanalyse oder mit dem Tweet, dem Einsatz, dass das nämlich diese Fair-Steven-Spiel-Bürgung ist, dass man immer so Kinder mit ins Genre wirft. Also bei Jurassic Park und ET sind ja immer die Kinder, die dann irgendwie so, wo ich dann auch denke, ah nee, ich brauche jetzt ja keine Kinder, die von Dinos gefressen werden. Das reicht mir, wenn einfach die coolen Typen und so hops gehen. Hauptsache, es sieht gut aus. Und dann habe ich den James Bond-Film gesehen und fand ihn dann doch erstaunlich gut, weil genau die Herausforderung, die man sich genommen hat, am Ende ganz spezifisch Daniel Craig als Bond noch mal als Jammerlappen zu zeigen, ist gelungen. Ich finde auch das Finale toll.
Hat es dann halt mit Bond nichts mehr zu tun. Also wir spoilern jetzt hier. Es mag ja sein, dass manche den noch nicht gesehen haben, aber wir spoilern hier. Also ich will das nur mal sagen. James Bond rennt einem Kuscheltier hinterher. Ja. Also das will ich nicht sehen. Ich glaube, der passt natürlich genau in unsere Zeit. Das ist ja all das, was wir tagtäglich bei Twitter erleben können. Also diese extreme Wehleidigkeit, die ist ja da so präsent wie noch nie vorher im Bond. Aber ich hoffe, dass wir dann doch zu einer gewissen, ich möchte mal sagen, Härte zurückkommen.
Ja, mal sehen, was die nächste bringt. Eine Sache, dadurch schon gesagt, dass wir spoilern. Jetzt müssen wir mal richtig spoilern, denn eine Sache treibt mich oben, seit ich den James Bond gesehen habe. Der kam 2020 nicht ins Kino und die Legende sagt, es gab eine Pandemie in der Welt und die Kinos waren zu und man wollte den Film nicht niemanden zeigen, sondern man wollte ihn groß auf der großen Leinwand und so weiter aufführen. Es hätte sich nicht als Streaming-Angebot hergegeben. Dann guckt man jetzt diesen Film, ist immer noch Pandemie und plötzlich hört man ach so der Bösewicht, der neueste Dreh des Bösewichts sind kleine Nano-Viren, die man umprogrammieren kann. Hauptsache sie sind schon mal gespritzt. Danach stehen sie dem Bösen zur freien Verfügung und ich dachte mir so ein bisschen, Mann das hätte ich gerne 2020 gesehen.
Und hat Sarah Wagenknecht den Film vielleicht damals doch schon sehen können.
Ja, es fiel doch wirklich genau in die Zeit. Warum hat man uns das verwarrt? Das ist das Erstaunliche.
Und das finde ich ja so toll, wenn das Kino etwas antizipieren kann und ja genau mit solchen Ängsten, die wir bei den Corona-Leugnern erlebt haben und bei jetzt den Impfverweigerern, hat ja Bond immer schon gespielt. Also solche Sachen gab es ja immer wieder, dass man da was gespritzt bekommt, das dann auch drin bleibt. Das ist ja schon auch etwas, womit Bond selbst ausgestattet wird, um überwacht zu werden von dem neuen Cue. Und das war immer ja auch so eine Bedrohung, die dann, nachdem man nicht mehr nur diese kalten Krieggeschichten erzählen konnte, man sah, also wir haben vielleicht pandemische Ausnahmezustände, die einen Super-Bösewicht produzieren kann. Und wenn du dir das Narrativ der Verschwörungstheoretiker ansiehst, dann erinnert das ja sehr stark an das, wie Blofeld in den Bond-Filmen gezeichnet wird. Das ist halt jetzt dann Bill Gates. Und das war dann mal eine Weile George Soros. Also das kann man ja sehr schön da übertragen. Und ich glaube auch, dass dieser Film uns gut getan hätte, hätte man veröffentlicht. Also ich bin jetzt natürlich sehr dankbar, ihn im Kino gesehen zu haben und möchte ihn ungern bei Netflix verbraten haben und so was. Aber jetzt einfach mal so diagnostisch gesehen, würde ich sagen, wäre das toll gewesen, wenn man sagt, wir haben das hier jetzt schon mal für euch antizipiert, liebe Verschwörungstheoretiker. Ihr braucht jetzt nicht hier Fanfiction und so zu machen. Wir haben ja das schon so fiktionalisiert, haben das auch wirklich mit guten Anzügen ausgestattet und tollen Kleidern. Insofern erspart euch das Ganze in den Foren. Hier könnt ihr euch das mal ansehen, aber es ist halt Fiktion. Also eigentlich ist das was sehr, sehr entlastendes, wenn man das dann so sieht.
Ja, es hätte der Debatte, für wann war James Bond angekündigt? Für November 2020 oder früher noch?
Nein, nein, der wäre im Anfang April angelaufen. Ich hatte, glaube ich, ja sogar schon eine Einladung für die Pressevorführungen oder so. Ja, also wenn mich nicht alles täuscht, also sonst.
Ja, nee, ich erinnere mich gerade. Der wurde dann auf November verschoben und dann nochmal über den Winter hinaus verschoben. Wenn man den tatsächlich im April 2020 gezeigt hätte und im November wäre die Impfung da gewesen, hätte man allen Schwurbler sagen können, ja, ich habe auch James Bond gesehen, aber jetzt gehe ich zum Arzt und hole mir meine Impfung. Und wir hätten sehr viele Debatten, sehr viel abgekürzt, glaube ich. Ja, also da lag ein ganz großes Angebot an die Welt in diesem James Bond Film, aber aus, ich nehme an, es waren am Ende tatsächlich die ökonomischen Gründe, hat man der Welt diesen Film vorenthalten und es ist schade, denn kein Film hätte so gut in 2020 gepasst. In der Hinsicht wirklich faszinierend, was man da plötzlich so sieht auf der Leitwand, während man die ganze Zeit sowas schon im Hinterkopf mittelaufen hat, weil man ja auch in der Realität vorkommt. Und dann bei Bond sozusagen diese Fan-Fiction dazu sieht. Naja, zwei Filme sind in Ankündigung. Wir bleiben noch kurz beim Film. Batman und Matrix. Matrix kommt demnächst, denn man ließ es sich nicht nehmen. Es muss der 12.11.21 sein, wo Matrix in den Kinos kommt. 121121. Das finde ich natürlich sehr gut. Wir haben bisher nur einen Trailer. Und sehr viele jammern über Matrix 2 und 3. Ich nicht, aber ich jammer auch nicht über Star Wars 1, 2, 3. Welche Erwartungen hast du an Matrix? Wird uns dasselbe, aber nochmal anders, wie so häufig, serviert? Oder können wir eigentlich nochmal von Lara was ganz Neues erwarten?
Nun, ich glaube, wir werden schon einen Film sehen, der sich mit der Matrix-Rezeption auch auseinandersetzen muss. Denn in rechten Kreisen, in Verschwörungskreisen, ist ja Matrix ein Referenzpunkt, um zu sagen, naja, willst du dann jetzt die blaue oder die rote Pille, komm hier zu uns, hier erfährst du, wie es wirklich ist. Und auch das Thema Kaninchenbau ist ja etwas, was bei Matrix angelegt ist. Wir sehen es jetzt auch schon wieder im Trailer, das Kaninchen-Tattoo. Und deswegen muss der Film, glaube ich, diese Rezeption auch mitdenken. Und das wird doch in irgendeiner Weise geschehen. Was mich allerdings noch viel mehr interessieren würde, ist, ob diese Erkenntnis, dass es da diese andere Welt gibt. Aber wer will da leben? Das ist ja gerade bei zwei und drei so schrecklich zu sehen. Will man da mit in so komischen Ritualen leben und so merkwürdige Kittel tragen? Und da ist man dann wieder bei seinen Wurzeln. Das ist vielleicht eine Welt, die Harald Wälzer vorschwebt. Darüber werden wir heute noch sprechen können. Mir ist die Simulation lieber. Und ich hätte jetzt eigentlich gerne einen vierten Teil, der sich richtig affirmativ in die Simulation hineinwirft und sagt, ja, es war toll.
Ja, also wir kriegen einen Trailer, der uns viele Anschlüsse verspricht. Der gleiche, die allererste Szene ist ja ein Therapeut in der Matrix, der dann auf Deutsch nur leider sagt, wir verwenden diese Worte hier nicht im Englischen, in hier. Also er spricht so richtig von hier drinnen. Ja, sagen wir das nicht. Dieser kleine Schlenker wird in der deutschen Übersetzung nicht mitgemacht, was ich komisch finde. Ich glaube, es ist nur eine Nachlässigkeit, denn ich verspreche mir auch viel von dem Film auch in die Richtung, wie du es eben schon gesagt hast, dass uns doch und da spielt ja nun also der Trailer findet eine Simulation statt. Soweit kann man ja sagen, dass wir dann doch noch mal vielleicht einfach eine Verdrehung von Utopie und Dystopie und so weiter. Und damit, bevor wir über Squid Game sprechen, wo das ja auch eine große Rolle ist, Batman, aber nur ganz kurz. Wir erleben und erleiden, dass alle Filme immer wieder neu gemacht werden. Alle fünf Jahre kommt ein neuer Spider-Man, alle vier, fünf Jahre kommt ein neuer Batman und so weiter und so fort.
Ich stelle dir heute das Buch von Bob Iger vor, von dem Disney-Chef. Dann wird einem auch einiges klar.
Da wird uns das erklärt, wie das funktioniert. Genau, denn im Grunde sind wir alle kleine Kinder im Kino.
Fünf-
bis zwölfjährige sagen, wieso soll ich mir den Film angucken? Den kenne ich doch noch gar nicht. Du hast dich schon immer drüber lustig gemacht, aber so ist es, mit Kindern Filme auszuwählen. In der Ansicht hat Disney das schon ganz clever gemacht. Ein nicht sehr umfangreiches, aber eben bekanntes Angebot, einfach in sein Disney Plus zu packen, sodass alle Kinder, mein Lieblingsfilm ist der 2. von links oben. Ist doch klar, klickt ihn mal an jetzt. So ungefähr ist ja der Filmkonsum der Minderjährigen. Und in Batman, und da haben wir auch schon Fernsehserien, zum Beispiel Gotham oder so, die eigentlich gar nicht so sehr Handlungen im Mittelpunkt stellen, oder Batman jetzt auch, ist ja alles überall, sondern eigentlich nur noch die Welt, die man eigentlich schon kennt, noch mal in Nuancen anders zeigen. Noch mal hier, da ein bisschen was gedreht oder auch für Kindertauglichkeit getrimmt oder wie auch immer. Und dieser neue Batman, den wir da sehen, der scheint mir noch mal so ins absolut Megadüstere zu gehen, wie auch schon dieser Joker-Film, der das so Verständnis-Pornografie, hat es ja Adrian Taub genannt, in seiner Zeitbesprechung. Und ich verspreche mir aber ehrlich gesagt, dass mal wieder viel von diesem neuen Batman-Film, den wir da sehen, mit Patterson, oder wie er heißt, als wir kennen ihn ja schon, als Zombie und so. In Tenet haben wir ihn ja auch schon in so einer Nuance, in einer anderen Rolle gesehen. Im Grunde bleibt er immer doch nah bei sich und seinem Gesicht irgendwie.
Also schon so ein Schauspieler, den man so bucht als Typ, nicht wenn man eine lustige Komödie mal drehen will, dann ist er vielleicht nicht der richtige.
Genau, er ist so der nachträgliche Typ, der dann nochmal mit den Haaren im Gesicht hängen lässt. Genau, so ein bisschen bedankenschwingen lässt.
Finster. Man weiß nicht so recht, was passiert, wenn die Tür zugeht. Ja.
Und ich bin eigentlich ein großer Vorfreude auf diesen Batman-Film, weil er so düster und so dunkel ist. Und vielleicht nochmal, während Christopher Nolan das alles so mega klug machen wollte und so, einfach nochmal ins, pff, das ist halt Batman.
Nee, ich möchte ja wenn, dann schon auch einen politisch relevanten Film, also wie das bei Christopher Nolan war. Mit der Düsternis komme ich gut zurecht, aber ich würde doch mir wünschen, dass es nicht einfach nur so ein DC-Spektakel dann wird. Denn das habe ich jetzt mit Marvel ja in den letzten Monaten auch wieder ganz, ganz viel erlebt. Und es ist einfach entsetzlich. Es ist auch keine Spannung mehr da. Und du siehst ja, da haben unglaublich viele Leute rumprogrammiert, damit das dann am Ende so aussehen konnte. Und du guckst auf die Uhr und denkst gut, jetzt hat das Finale begonnen. Das dauert jetzt etwa 40 Minuten. Dann kommt so ein melancholischer Abschied. Dann wird noch mal zu einzelnen Erdteilen und Personengruppen geblendet, die dann noch mal ganz sentimental sagen, nun weiß ich, wo mein Weg ist, oder ich habe immer auf mein Herz gehört. Und dann kommt der Abspann. Und dann kommt aber noch mal, wie es denn weitergeht. Also das ist für mich nicht mehr auszuhalten, diese Dramaturgie. Insofern hoffe ich, dass da man überlegt, was kann man eigentlich jetzt mit Batman heute erzählen? Also in den Neuen Zwanzigern. Das ist ja auch immer wieder eine Frage, wenn man das schon macht. Also wenn man immer wieder auf diese Figuren zurückgreift, dann kann man es ja fast so ein bisschen wie das Regie-Theater an der Oper oder so tun. Also es ist nicht so wie am Stadttheater, beim Schauspiel, wo man sich oft ganz entfernt dann vom Text. Aber bei der Oper ist ja so, es muss gespielt werden, die Musik ist da, da wird doch in der Regel nicht unterbrochen. Aber was mache ich, wenn ich heute Carmen inszenieren will? Genau. In welcher Fabrik arbeitet die? Ist das eine Zigarettenfabrik? Ist das eine Shipfabrik in Wuhan oder was ist denn das eigentlich? Und solche Fragen kann man natürlich auch stellen, wenn man jetzt eine Neuinszenierung von Batman macht.
Genau. Und da ist, glaube ich, viel möglich in diesem Kulissenbau, der da einfach stattfindet. Gerade weil Gotham einfach...
Als Mikrokosmos sehr gut ist, um das zu machen. Das ist eigentlich viel günstiger als Marvel, die immer den ganzen Globus mitdenken müssen.
Richtig.
Gotham City ist man sehr viel enger und kann damit besser das auch so als Experimentierfeld nehmen.
Ja, hat ja Nolan perfekterweise einfach alle Brücken gesprengt und hat uns mal Gotham gezeigt. Ja. Also ziemlich perfekt. Gut, Squid Game. Ich habe natürlich deine Filmanalysen dazu auch gesehen. Ich habe auch ein bisschen gelesen. Ja, klar, immer so der Kapitalismus hier und da und der Spaß der einen. Es wird ja auch viel da, also Gage spielt ja so eine mega Rolle. Sie sind alle freiwillig da. Also das liegt alles zu offenbar, finde ich. Ich will aber eine Frage noch mal mit dir besprechen. Dystopie und Utopie, die sind jetzt da drin in diesem Spiel. Und zwar freiwillig. Spätestens nach der ersten Runde haben sie sich alle freiwillig entschieden. Wir machen das noch mal mit, nachdem sie vorher auch schon mal anders entschieden haben. Wenn auch nicht individuell, sondern dann nur kollektiv, aber individuell waren sie dann alle freiwillig dabei. Also es liegt an einem Verständnis vor. So, und jetzt ist das ja sehr erfolgreich über alle Landkreise. Das ist ja wirklich erstaunlich, dass das überall funktioniert. Und ich finde es trotzdem von sehr, sehr großer Bedeutung, dass das in Südkorea spielt. Und Südkorea ist ein Landkreis, in dem wir wissen, wie arm die Alten sind, nämlich 50 Prozent, ich habe es ja schon öfter gesagt, leben unter der Armutsschwelle. Die Häuser, in denen sie leben, werden vom Staat gestellt, weil es schon gar keinen Sinn mehr macht, das nach Marktprinzipen zu verteilen. Die haben eh kein Geld, aber die müssen halt irgendwo leben und ihre Rente oder ihr Lebensamt dann noch durchbringen und so weiter. Und Alter spielt jetzt nicht so eine Rolle. Also wir sehen einen sehr alten Typ, aber der hat ja auch eine besondere Rolle. Die anderen sind jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig alt, aber sie sind jung. Und ich habe mich die ganze Zeit immer schon gefragt, und da ist Südkorea und Japan. An denen Beispiel muss man es machen. Was bedeutet Rentenrepublik für die Jungen, die nicht Rentner sind, sondern die für die Rentner noch da sein müssen? Entweder weil es ihre eigenen Eltern sind, um die sie sich sorgen, oder kollektiv über, was weiß ich, Steuern, Umlage und so weiter.
Oder drittens, zum Amüsement der alten Reichen. Das ist ja, wenn du so willst, die Schlusspointe des Ganzen. Wir wollen jetzt nicht so viel auch hier spoilern. Vielleicht hat das man es ja noch nicht gesehen.
Genau, mir geht es gar nicht um...
Ja, aber so kann man es ja mal sagen. Es ist auch die Frage, für wen das Spektakel stattfindet.
Genau, die jungen Südkoreaner, und damit nehme ich jetzt mal alle unter 50, also die kann man noch als Dachdecker los schicken und so weiter, die sind zum Amüsement der Alten da. Denn die Unternehmen und so weiter werden von alten Leuten geführt. Das ist eine ganz klare Hierarchie nach Alter, in Japan ja auch. Und die jungen werden ja so richtig ausgequetscht. Und diese schicksalhaften Biografien, die wir in Squid Game sehen, die dazu führen, dass die wirklich mit Einverständnis wissen, worauf sie sich einlassen, sagen okay, die nächsten fünf Runden nehme ich hier freiwillig teil. Das wurde mir in den Rezensionen, das kam mir zu kurz.
Das ist aber auch schade, dass die Serie das dann so zuspitzt, nur noch auf dieses Spektakel, wie blutig wird jetzt das nächste Game. Ich würde sagen, die ersten beiden Folgen haben schon eine enorme Kraft und auch eine diagnostische Kraft. Und das lässt aber dann irgendwann nach. Dann sind das mehr so zwischenmenschliche Dinge, die sich da ergeben. Aber eigentlich war das interessant, dieses noch mal rausgehen aus dem Spiel, noch mal sagen, jetzt noch mal in diese harte Wirklichkeit und zu fragen, ob das die Alternative sein kann. Und die Antwort lautet nein, deswegen geht man zurück ins Spiel.
Genau, und die Befürchtung, die ich so ein bisschen habe, ist, dass je nachdem, wo das auf der Welt gesehen wird, also das Schauspiel so wie wir es bekommen, ich finde nicht, dass es besonders gut geschauspielert ist oder besonders raffiniert, du hast ja auch gesagt, es ist jetzt keine besondere Kameraarbeit oder so, die da irgendwie auffällig ist, sondern es sind halt viele Farben mit Musik, da wird ein bisschen eindrücklich gearbeitet. Aber meine Befürchtung ist, dass sich die Publikar, je nach Nation, sehr unterschiedlich zur Frage verhalten, ob das jetzt dystopisch oder utopisch ist. Also ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen, dass man in Südkorea sich das so anguckt oder in Japan und denkt, klar, Menschen sterben. Ich meine, das sind auch Leute in Moria verhungern und so weiter. Das passiert ja nicht direkt vor unserer Haustür, wir haben da auch keinen Fernseher, machen keine Fernseh-Show draus, aber das Scratch mal jetzt irgendwie sagt, wir müssen jetzt mal Mauern bauen, um uns wehrhaft zu zeigen gegen Flüchtlinge, die irgendwie barbuß und verhungert da in Polen im Wald sitzen. Das geht ja schon sehr in die Richtung. Und über diese Rolle, dass das Geld da so sichtbar auch ist, also diese große Kugel oben am Firmament, der Hoffnung, der Silberstreif, der Stern von Bethlehem, wie auch immer, hängt da dieses große Geld. Es ist einige, sage ich mal so, sich die sehr angucken und denken, ah, da würde ich auch gerne mal mitspielen, so wie wenn ich Big Brother gucke, ja, und denke, also das amerikanische Big Brother, cooles Spiel, würde ich auch gerne mal mitspielen. Dass man so eine Serie guckt und denkt, ich glaube, ich könnte das gewinnen.
Naja, wir haben, glaube ich, diese Konstellation. Ja, du hast es jetzt mit den Flüchtlingen beschrieben. Wir sprechen da nächste Woche bei Wohlstand vor allem mal drüber, warum sich Menschen auf den Weg machen und so viel riskieren. Und du hast dann einfach eine ungleiche Welt, nicht nur Ungleichheit innerhalb der Länder, sondern zwischen den Ländern. Und die zwischen den Ländern nimmt dann zu bei vielen Abschnitten. Also es ist dann so, dass 1960 ein Spanier viermal reicher war als ein Marokkaner. Und heute ist das so, der ist siebenmal reicher als ein Marokkaner. Also das ist was, was Branko Milanovic alles dann sehr schön aufzeigen kann. Und dann siehst du einfach, dass Leute so etwas auf sich nehmen. Und dann ist auch dieser Begriff Wirtschaftsflüchtling der albernste überhaupt, weil man einfach sehen kann, ja, die Unterschiede sind so drastisch, welchen da braucht man nicht noch sagen. Ja, aber gab es dann auch noch einen Krieg? Oder ist da sonst noch, ist man da auch noch sonst irgendwie diskriminiert worden? Nee, das ist der Grund, warum man geht. Und das ist, glaube ich, etwas, weshalb die Serie so verstanden wird überall und wahrscheinlich aber anders gelesen wird. Also man müsste jetzt wahrscheinlich qualitative und quantitative Umfragen machen bei all den Zuschauern aller Welt. Das wäre eine interessante Studie. Und das mal, um zu vergleichen, was da eigentlich so gesehen wird und wie das dann rückgebunden wird an die eigene Situation, in der man lebt.
Genau, man bräuchte eigentlich mal so ein ganz kluges Fokusgruppengespräch mit jungen Erstwählern FDP über Squid Game, was die da eigentlich sehen. Denn ich glaube, das ist sehr erschreckend. Also ich finde, Squid Game ist nicht nur einfach eine Fernsehshow, sondern da muss man jetzt auch die Rezeption sich mal genau anschauen, um da doch einiges noch darüber zu sagen. Auf der anderen Seite will ich die Serie jetzt nicht besonders loben oder so. Ich habe mich die ganze Zeit geärgert, dass das nicht mal mit Raffinesse wie bei Westworld oder so. Also gutes Denkmaterial, aber das heißt nicht mit Raffinesse aufgearbeitet wurde, sondern dann doch mehr so hingerotzt eigentlich.
Ja, man muss es als Phänomen begreifen und als Phänomen es zu analysieren, ist hochinteressant. Und wenn man sich diese Pyramiden-Modelle ansieht, die Coaches immer präsentieren und dann ihren Jüngern, die dann hunderttausendfach da sind, irgendwelche Coachings buchen, ihnen sagen, du musst da an der Spitze der Pyramide stehen, dann leuchtet ja jedem ein, dass hunderttausend nicht an der Spitze einer Pyramide stehen können, sondern nur einer oder ganz wenige. Und dass aber genau dieses System akzeptiert wird und ich glaube auch sehr von jungen Leuten akzeptiert wird und das führt dann auch zu einem solchen Erfolg, wie wir ihn bei der FDP beobachten können. Ja, genau.
Ja, also da geht es ein bisschen ins Eingemachte. Wir gehen jetzt auch ins Eingemachte, lesen Harald Wälzers Nachruf auf sich selbst.
Ich sag dir gleich, ich bin on fire.
Kann ich mir vorstellen.
Ich bin wirklich on fire. Also dieses Buch ärgert mich maßlos.
Ich bin gespannt, dann darfst du da gleich einsteigen.
Und das kannst du eigentlich auch nicht gut finden. Ich habe bei vielen Abschnitten gesagt, das wirst du doch jetzt nicht.
Ich finde es auch nicht gut.
Wirst du irgendeine Piroete drehen, um mir zu sagen, nein, das ist alles ganz anders. Aber ich bin sehr gespannt. Also es wird, glaube ich, sehr heiter, diese Diskussion darüber. Und wir können, also du hast ja schon eigentlich den Begriff eingebracht, das letzte Mal, ehe wir das Buch gelesen hatten, Dekadentologie. Und ich glaube, diesen Begriff der Dekadentologie, den sollten wir jetzt fortspinnen. Und der wird uns, glaube ich, auch in den nächsten Jahren begleiten. Was hast du noch gelesen?
Ja, also zur Welt, so mein Teaser ist, man kann durchaus ohne Fundament Luftschlösser bauen. Es ist ganz erstaunlich. Es schwebt dann halt so vor sich hin. Chi Jinping, wir haben ja uns hier schon darüber verständigt, dass es über ihn keine richtigen Biografien gibt, außer die offizielle und Wikipedia Artikel. Und ich würde sagen, Stefan Aust und Kollegen haben jetzt aus dem Wikipedia-Material, dass da ist so eine Art Biografie, in der sie da doch wieder sehr viel Exkurs zu China und so weiter schreiben gemacht. Trotzdem ein paar interessante Aspekte. Dann gucken wir kurz, nachdem wir alle über Facebook jetzt so viel sprechen, mal ins richtige Antitrust-Lager. Was ist eigentlich bei Apple und Amazon los? Ganz erstaunliche investigative Arbeiten hier bei Reuters und der Financial Times. Dann der Zustandsbericht Afghanistan, den habe ich ja angekündigt. Thomas Rothig, da habe ich noch nicht gelesen. Jetzt habe ich ihn gelesen. Das ist wirklich schlimm. Alles, was wir befürchtet haben, wird wahr. Und finale bei mir ist Rentnerpublik. Die 37-jährigen Chefs, Neuchefs, haben Angst vor ihren 23-jährigen Mitarbeitern. Emma Goldberg hat in der New York Times einen ziemlich quatschigen Text geschrieben, der aber zur Zeit diagnostisch doch einiges bietet. Also in der Hinsicht, da gucken wir noch mal kurz rein dann.
Sehr gut. Wie gesagt, wir werden über das Buch des Disney-Chefs sprechen, werden uns aber nur konzentrieren auf die Übernahmen. Pixar, Star Wars, Marvel. Da wird es interessant. Da kommt Steve Jobs dann sehr häufig vor, nicht nur, wenn es um Pixar geht. Dann habe ich noch dieses Buch gelesen, Wir Komplizen der Schönheit, ein ehemaliger Freund von Karl Lagerfeld, erzählt ein bisschen. Kein wirklich starkes Buch, aber so einen Aspekt möchte ich rausgreifen. Dann schon angekündigt Rentnerrepublik in Japan. Wie gehen die Banken damit um? Wenn zum Beispiel da ständig Leute anrufen und sagen, ich habe mein Sparbuch verloren. Und die sagen, aber sie waren doch eben noch mit dem Sparbuch da. Also wenn die Kunden dement werden, ein interessantes Thema. Dann Bettina Gauss ist gestorben. Und wir blicken nochmal auf ihren, glaube ich, letzten Text, den sie geschrieben hat. Sie hat sich nämlich zum Fall Reichelt geäußert und warnte da bei aller Härte, die man an den Tag legen müsste gegen Reichelt, vor Brüderie. Und wir haben noch einen Text von Branko Milanovic, der einmal sagt, wie man Ökonomie betrachten kann, womit man sich da beschäftigen kann, ob es jetzt einfach nur darum geht, ja, Kosten Nutzen abzuwägen oder ob Ökonomie auch noch ein bisschen mehr sein kann und was er dann darunter versteht. Das also steht an. Und ich will sagen, wir sind quasi avantgarde mit dem Salon. In der ersten Ausgabe hatte ich doch nochmal zur Lektüre empfohlen in Stahlgewittern von Ernst Jünger. Und wer hat drauf gehört? Elon Musk. Elon Musk hat vor wenigen Tagen getwittert, Almost finished Jüngers Storm of Steel. Intense. Great book.
Ja, sehr gut. Wir stehen hier auf gute Werturteile. Gleich gibt es viele davon im Salon. Wir gehen mal rüber. Bis gleich.
Bis gleich.